um  [Music]  [Music]  me  [Music]  [Music]  i have another chance allah says in the  quran every soul shall taste death and  when your body is washed and put under  the ground you will wish that there is  some good deeds coming towards you if  you teach someone salah you will get the  reward of every single prayer they do  our aim is to teach 10 000 people how to  praise allah this ramadan if you donate  and somebody learns how to pray through  your donation even when you're in your  grave you keep getting those rewards and  not only that when they teach their kids  and their grandkids you are getting  every single reward imagine being in  your grave and hundreds if not thousands  of people are praying just because of  you we are just looking for a thousand  people only to give a hundred pounds to  reach our target trust me you will wish  you took this opportunity when you're in  your grave click the button or the link  and donate now